my name's Lila Maxwell I run a think
tank on international development in
London call the Overseas Development
Institute I just heard Bill Clinton say
in the plenary Hall how important it is
to remember that this is a global
community in which some of the people
most affected by the crisis are amongst
the poorest on the planet and that's a
really important statement because
there's a tendency to think about the
financial crisis has been something that
mainly affects developed countries and
the deter price it's that will be solved
in developed countries is my the reverse
terran vs trojan we're seeing the
recession rolling out infecting many
poor countries and many poor people on
top of the food crisis and fuel crisis
of last year we now see countries very
badly affected by lower of admittances
for migrant workers by falling prices
and if or even for the export of goods
and services tourism receipts for
example forming the reversal of foreign
direct investment and repatriation of a
portfolio flow to developing countries
these are competing countries very hard
Kenya for example has lost something my
relative the scent of its storage
revenue go forty percent of its religion
seized and if growth falters in those
countries it will have a very similar in
turn affect and the poorest people and
those costs will be irreversible because
children who are affected by
malnutrition for example in the areas
news'matt healthier their ability to
learn their adult productivity so what
do we have to do we have to make sure
that you tell a story about of the
session which puts developing countries
fully at the table and their voice must
be fully ho in detectives on the phone
we need to make sure that the protection
measures are available to stop this
crisis effect is important and we need
to think about poor countries as part of
the solution as well as just part of the
pool and investment in developing
countries can play a big part in
providing the booster global growth that
is on so many people's minds here at
Davos we have a number of important
opportunities coming up in the next few
months starting with the g20 meeting in
london in april the g20 is not a perfect
formulation
many in developing countries but it's a
good start we need to build on it and
make sure that the measures we can take
to deal with our session don't just
affect us in the north but really work
for all peoples around the world as you
don't have a possible approach to policy
making but let's see them evident from
need exactly 20 meeting in London under
British leadership in April